I understand you are incredibly limber
you have incredible skills is this true
oh yeah yeah and I didn't get to this
last time and I don't know exactly what
it is you can do but I've told that you
are quite a limber man
yeah okay you know I did like martial
arts and stuff as a kid so like I can
like yeah I can do that but yeah okay
well that's the thing
what is that what did you sound like I
can what martial art is that this is the
kickee legi oh wow I can do like a
jumping toe touch yeah yeah can we see
the jumping Tojo yeah yeah hope I don't
rip the butt out of my pants I really
love the part where the microphone came
flying in that's the signature spam
there were some people to credit thought
he's on dialysis and in trouble yeah
you